OUR GOVERNOR TO FINANCE
COMMITTEE MEETING WE HAVE ONE
BILL TODAY TO PRESENT WE WANT
TO WELCOME SENATOR MCGUIRE TO
HIS OWN COMMITTEE AND IT'S AN
HONOR TO HAVE WORKED WITH YOU
THIS YEAR. SENATE MCGUIRE
REALLY. WE'RE GONNA HAVE A MISS
LANCHESTER CALL THE ROLL AND
WE'LL GET THIS GOING MCGUIRE
WHY PRESENT MORE LOT PRESENT
MORE LIKE PRESIDENT BELL. THE
PRESIDENT HERTZBERG. THE TITLE
NIELSEN ALSO PRESIDENT WIENER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM CENTER WHERE
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR I BELIEVE
WE'RE ALL OPPOSE THE BILL HAVE
OF COURSE. ALL RIGHT HEY WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE
CHAIR AND I WANT TO TAKE MY OWN
UP TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE VICE
CHAIR FOR. ALL OF THE WORK THIS
YEAR AND WE GIVEN VERY SPECIAL
HONOR IT WAS THE FIRST HEARING
THAT HE HAD MISSED HI THIS PAST
HEARING AND HE ACTUALLY GOT THE
AWARD FOR THE FIRST TIME SO.
I'M SURPRISED YOU'RE
CONGRATULATIONS SIR I AND THEN
I JUST ONE LAST ITEM MISTER
VICE CHAIR IS SOMEONE IS A
SHORT TIMER. HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE IN ITS TO THE
GENTLEMAN TO MY RIGHT. SO.
THINKING ABOUT RETIREMENT MR
CARE GOOD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TALK WITH US ABOUT IT BECAUSE
IT'S NOT GONNA BE THE SAME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
PUTTING ME ON THE SPOT YES I'M
GONNA RETIRE ON THE THIRTIETH
AFTER ABOUT THREE YEARS AROUND
THE CAPITAL TWENTY ONE FOR THE
LEAGUE AND WORKING IN THE
LEGISLATURE. IT'S BEEN A REAL
PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH ALL OF
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THE
RECOGNITION APPRECIATE THAT
LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHARACTER. BUT
I THINK WE TO GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE PLEASE. HE HE HAS BEEN
THE VOICE. FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AT FOR OVER TWO DECADES. HE IS
TENACIOUS HE IS FOCUSED. IN HE
IS. UP IN THE BUSINESS. I AM
MAKING SURE THAT CITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. ARE GETTING THEIR
DUE. IN THIS ONE TAKE A MOMENT.
TO RECOGNIZE HIM AND SAY THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK
AND IT IS NOT GONNA BE THE SAME
WITHOUT YOU IN IT IS A- LOSS
FOR THE LEAGUE AS WELL. SO MY
GOODNESS AND MISSED. IT IS AN
HONOR TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT SB
THREE FORTY FOR ITS- ITS FOCUS
ON THE EASIEST PART OF THIS
BILL. AND THAT'S A ONE YEAR
SUNSET EXTENSION WE WILL BE
BACK WITH THE TOUGH PART NEXT
YEAR WHICH ARE WHICH ARE THE
ALL THE RULES AND BREAKS. LONG
STORY SHORT THREE FOUR FOUR. IS
CAN PROVIDE THAT ONE YEAR
EXTENSION TO ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COLLECT. ON
LOCAL UTILITY USER TAX IS. FOR
ME TO SAY A PREPAID WIRELESS
TELECOMMUNICATION. IN SERVICES
WHAT WE KNOW IS THIS THIS
ABILITY EXPIRES AT THE END OF
THIS CALENDAR YEAR THIS BILL
EXTENDED THROUGH JANUARY FIRST.
OF TWENTY TWENTY IT ONLY
APPLIES TO LOCAL IMPOSED. VOTER
PROVE UTILITY USER TAX IS NOT
THE PROVISIONS OF AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN THAT WERE OVERTURNED
BY THE COURTS AS WE ALL KNOW.
AT THE DID THE DECISION IT WILL
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL CLEANUP OF
WHICH WILL BE COMING NINE NEXT
YEAR AND DO KNOW THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE A HEAVIER LEFT.
ALSO THIS IS THIS REVENUE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS. IS GENERATED FROM THE
SALES AND I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT ALSO TO SAY THANK YOU
DAN FOR ALL OF HIS WORK ON THIS
HE'S BEEN WONDERFUL AND I HOPE
THESE CAN BE COMING BACK. FOR
THE IN A BILL IN THE HEAD. IN
HIS SHORTS SANDALS IN A
MARGARITA. MR KERRY IS YOUR
FIRST WITNESS YES SENATOR DO WE
REALLY HAVE TO LIVE LISTEN TO A
QUITTER G. HI DEAL. ON THIRTY
YEARS AS A WHILE SO ANYWAY
THANK YOU SENATOR APPRECIATE
THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN IN
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL OF THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM FOR OVER A
HUNDRED CITIES INSTABLE
COUNTIES END OBVIOUSLY AS A
JUROR SAID THERE HAS TO BE SOME
WORK DONE NEXT YEAR IN TERMS OF
A MORE CON A COMPREHENSIVE OR
WORKING IN THIS AREA OF LAW BUT
YOU APPRECIATE THAT THE
EXTENSION SO THAT WAS COMING.
IN CONTINUE TO BENEFIT FROM
REVENUE AND HOPEFULLY NEXT TWO
MORE MINUTES OF CLIP OUT THAT.
WORK MORE. UNDER LASTING SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT. THE TEACHER
NUMBER STEVE KERR ALSO PROCEED
TA RESPONSES OF THE BILL
NINETEEN FOR THE TWENTY FOURTH
THE BILL LEAVE IT WAS STAND I
WORK TOGETHER ON IT THERE MIGHT
THAT. A LARGE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS. WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING ON SOME OF
THE CLEANUP STUFF FOR NEXT YEAR
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT BILL. BOTH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. ARE IN OLD
RETAILERS MARLYS INDUSTRY
BECAUSE WE MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW THAT THESE FUNDS ARE
COLLECTED AND GO TO THE PLACE
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE IT'S
JUST A MORE COMPLICATED ON
PREPAID THAT IT IS. THROUGH
YOUR YOUR NORMAL CONTRACTUAL I
ALSO WAS ASKED BY OUR
COLLEAGUES TO BEAUTY SERVICES
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT. THEY
REPRESENT THE HUNDRED OR SO
THIS USE THAT TO COLLECT THESE.
AND SO THE WANTED ME TO. ADD
THEIR SUPPORT AS WELL. IT IS
THE GREAT OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IN YOUR
STRUCTURE MEMBERS W. WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU JEFF. THANK YOU TURN
SENATORS JOHN INSTITUTING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THAT IS ALL THE ON A ON
BEHALF OF TRACK PHONE WE
SUPPORT. I WOULD ALL. OF
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION SPORT. THANK YOU
THANKS FOR COMING ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. BILL CENTRE BELL.
NOT FOR NOW BUT THIS IS GOING
TO BE WORKED ON BETWEEN NOW AND
NEXT YEAR I THINK IT'S VERY
ANALYZE THE IMPACT ON. LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS ESPECIALLY
PEOPLE ON FIXED INCOMES PEOPLE
THAT HAVE. I KNOW PEOPLE HAVE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
TYPICALLY USE THESE TYPES OF
PHONES SO I'VE I'VE JUST WANTED
A SIGNAL THAT ARE OUT THERE SO
WE CAN. EXPLORE OBJECT OF
WHETHER WHETHER OR NOT WE
SHOULD ACCOMMODATE SOME CONCERN
ABOUT THAT. SO I'M JUST RISEN
OUT NOW SO YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT.
AND MAYBE DO SOME RESEARCH THE
TIME. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
MISTER KIRK SINCE THIS IS YOUR
LAST MEETING I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS FOR YOU. THE S.
SENATOR SAID THAT IS TWENTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN SALES
PER YEAR. I AND I'M SHOWING
THAT IT RAISES SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN. UTILITY TAX IS THAT
ACCURATE THAT'S THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE CONSULTS ANALYSIS
WHICH JACKSON WAS VERY GOOD.
RATED THAT IS ACCURATE IN THAT
ARE SEVEN HUNDRED THAT'S WHAT
SEVEN OF FIFTY THOUSAND A YEAR
TO ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM. MY
UNDERSTANDING THE SIX MILLION
DOLLARS WAS FROM DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION SO
THERE WAS THE ANNUAL I BELIEVE
THE TWENTY FOUR MILLION AS THE
TILL SIX. Q. MOTIVE YEAH. I
THINK THE FIRST YEAR THERE WAS
SOME. IT TOOK ABOUT A YEAR TO
SET UP THE PROGRAM SO I'M I'M
I'M LOOKING AT MAYBE FIVE AND
IT. POINT TWO FIVE MILLION NET.
SO THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A LOT
A LOT OF MONEY SO I'M I WANTED
MAYBE PUT IT IN CONTEXT SENATOR
IT'S- THE INCEPTION. GROWTH
WHENEVER SINCE INCEPTION BUT
BUT MAYBE SIX MILLION A YEAR
AND REVENUES. SO BUT THIS IS
JUST FOR CERTAIN MUNICIPALITIES
ARE WE- TALKING ABOUT JUST
THOSE ON A WESTERNER ONE CITIES
IN THREE COUNTIES WHO CURRENTLY
COLLECT YOU TEASE. SO AND THOSE
ARE DECISIONS ARE MADE BY THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND SELLS SO
THERE IS A HUNDRED ONE
CALIFORNIA CITIES. AND COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS ONE
FOR THE RECORD LITTLE
EXPLANATION ON THE PARITY ON
WHY YOU HAVE THE TAX FOR THE
CARDS. AND IT'S BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THE TAX AT THIS PHONE
BILLS. YOU COULD JUST EXPLAIN
IT JUST FOR THE RECORD MR KERRY
GUY COULD PULL THAT THE TAX ME
OBVIOUSLY ONE THING IF TAXES.
UNIFIED RELATE ACOSTA ACROSS
CONSUMERS AND OBVIOUSLY EASIER
TO CALL. SOMEONE HAS A PHONE
BILL AND THEY'RE THEY'RE PAYING
THE PHONE BILL WITH YOUR TO
CALL. HER BY REACH UP BERMAN IS
CHALLENGING THAT WAS THE REASON
FOR AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY WAS TO
HAVE A MECHANISM THAT COULD
ACTUALLY WORK. IN THE REACHED
ENVIRONMENT AND. TWENTY FOUR
MILLION THIS LANCHESTER DID YOU
HAVE ANY MORE QUESTIONS JOIN ME
TO ASK. OKAY THANKS FOR PASSING
THOSE OVER. THE CONGRATULATIONS
OF A GREAT RETIREMENT WHICH
VERSION ONE ISN'T PASSED YET HE
HAS A HE IS RETIRING WE HAD ALL
YOUR CARES CAN WE HAD A WE HAD
A BIG CEREMONY YOUR BEFORE YOU
ARRIVE JUST AND HEARD YOU WERE
CARRYING. IF YOU EVER SUPPORT A
BILL THAT DIDN'T HAVE TO DO
WITH MONEY OR YEP ECONOMY FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO I THINK
IT'S ONE. SHOT BEFORE THE IS TO
THE APPROPRIATE THAT WE HATE.
PLEASE ASK A QUESTION I'M ASKED.
WHY THE HECK WE DOING THIS BILL
THE DAY BEFORE LAST LAST
DECISION. THIS IS A COMPELLING
CASE THIS IS BEEN ON THE MOVE
AND OVER IN THE ASSEMBLY AND WE
ARE UNABLE TO SPEAK VERY CANDID
ABOUT IT. THEY'RE LOOKING AT A
LARGER FIX. ON THERE ARE GONNA
NEED TO BE SOME CHANGES TO THE
RULES AND RAGS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A HEAVY
LIFT WHICH IS GOING TO NEED TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE TIME. AND
SENATE ADVANCE ONE IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOCUS ON THOSE WHO ARE.
HAVE CHEN WHO ARE FOR
CALIFORNIANS OR FROM THE DD
COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S GOING TO
MEAN THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
SPEND THE FOLLOWING. HOLD BILL
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME COMPLEX
ISSUES THERE HAVE TO BE TACKLED
BUT THE SUNSET. NUMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY NINETEEN THIS
ONLY EXTENDS THE REVENUE
PORTION THROUGH JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE EXCUSE ME SO THAT'S
WHY WE'RE TAKING A TWO PRONGED
APPROACH TO THIS. THIS BILL IS
EMERGENCY ROOM. DON'T AND I
DON'T BELIEVE SO WHO IS THE SO
OF THE ITEM. HI MY HANDSOME.
AND BUT OUR JOB IS TO
PARTICULARLY AMONG OUR FRIENDS
TO. QUESTIONS THAT'S WERE
INTEGRITY LIES AND SO IT'S EASY
TO BEAT UP THE PEOPLE YOU DON'T
AGREE WITH. BUT I AND MY
QUESTION IS OKAY SO THIS GOES
INTO EFFECT ON JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY. AREN'T WERE THE
LAST DAY I THINK THAT IT. NO WE
ALL SCRATCH EACH OTHER'S BACKS
TO GET THESE THINGS DONE
SOMETIMES IS POLITICAL
COMPELLING REASONS AND
SOMETIMES IS URGENCY REASONS
FOR LITIGATION FOR COPS. WHY
COULDN'T YOU PUT THIS ACROSS
THE DESK ON THE FIRST OF
JANUARY THIRD G. PROVISION AND
GET IT PASSED AND- GIVE US A
CHANCE TO REALLY THINK ABOUT IT
WHAT'S A COMPELLING REASON
THERE WAS ANOTHER BILL. THAT
WAS. MOVING ON THAT LEFT OUT.
LOCAL UTILITY. TAXES AND SO WE
ARE HERE TODAY MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO CLEAN THIS UP.
AND THE PROGRAM IS ALREADY BEEN
SET UP BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION. IT THIS WAS
ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED BY AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN I IN
200-017-4014 EXCUSE ME TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. SO WE'RE
SIMPLY EXTENDING THE DEADLINE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE TAXES IS
AN IMPORTANT TAX REVENUE FOUR
HUNDRED ONE CITIES IN THREE
COUNTIES. IN THE STATE AND I
THINK THE OTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS BILL
THIS IS GENERAL FUND. NEUTRAL
THERE'S NO COST. AS THE DOLLAR
COMING FROM THE- PLEASE TAXES
ARE ALSO REIMBURSING THE
GENERAL FUND THE CROSSING. WE
DO THAT I MAY MAKE. I THINK YOU
HAD A DEBATE JUST EXTENDING THE
SUCH A YEAR WELL WE CAN CON THE
LARGER LARGER PIECES. AND WE
WOULD HAVE MUCH RATHER OF HAD.
IN BUDGET QUITE. CANDIDLY L.
AND FORTUNATELY I NOT MAKE IT.
WE ACTUALLY ASKED THAT IS.
TAKEN UP TO WHICH TO CUT IT.
TOOK A LITTLE TIME IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OPTED NOT TO
INCLUDED WITH THE NINE ONE ONE
PIECE OF THIS AND FOR. YOU KNOW
FOR THEIR OWN REASONS AND SO
THEN WE HAD TO KIND OF STEP
BACK INTO TO DO IT SEPARATELY.
WE HAD HOPED IT WOULD BE DONE
IN THE BUDGET BUT. AND THEY
WERE JUST TO ASK THE GOOD CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE TO. IF HIS
CLOSING REMARKS. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR THANKS TO OBTAIN BEARD
AT PRESENT IN AGAIN THAT WE
WILL BE BACK TACKLE IN THE
LARGER ISSUE NEXT YEAR IN ORDER
PROCEED AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
SIMPLE SUNSET EXTENSION. GOOD
ADAM. CALL THE ROLL AND THE OLD
WILL KNOW WE HAVE A MOTION
SENATOR NIELSEN MADE THE MOTION
SOMETIME AGO BUT WILL RETURN
THE BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR
WHICH IS. THE OBVIOUS THING TO
DO IN THE LAST. YOU HOURS OF
THE SESSION RIGHT. REQUIRE
REQUIRE. BLOCK AYE BELL BELL I
HERTZBERG WITH REGARD HER TITLE.
HELLO ALL RIGHT NIELSEN YES AND
I WIENER. AT SIX OH WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE AWARD
WINNING. SENATOR WIENER. YOU
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE IT
GIVES VICE CHAIR OF
. RESTLESS
WHAT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. HE
MISSED THE RECOGNITION OF MR
DAN CARE GAME CHARACTERS
RETIRING CENTER WHEN AFTER
TWENTY ONE YEARS WITH THE
LEAGUE THIRTY YEARS AROUND THE
BUILDING SO WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SAY ANYTHING ON BEHALF OF.
BUT YOU HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
FIFTY. LET'S NOT GO THERE RIGHT
YEAH SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT IN
BETTER ALL RIGHT. I LIKE IT I
LIKE IT LAZY GENTLEMAN. WE ARE
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE HERE IN
SB THREE FOUR FOUR AT THE
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO THE
MOTION IS RETURNED THE BILL TO
THE SENATE FLOOR MOTION MADE BY
SENATOR NIELSEN THIS I'M JUST
CHECKING PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT. WIENER HI HI IS A
GERMAN THAT IS A SEVEN ZERO
VOTE MISTER VICE CHAIR I
BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE A
PRESENTATION AN AWARD TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE TO MR WIENER TO
WRAP THIS UP HERE AT OUR FINAL
HEARING. FOR LATEST MEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER. CENTER WIENER
YOU'RE AN ALL STAR THANKS FOR
BEING LATE ALL THE TIME AND
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO BE THE
FIRST ONE HERE AT EVERY MEETING.
I WAS THE FIRST ONE TO THREE
DAY. EVEN FOR THE CHAIR. I ONLY
UPPER ACCURACY EXCEPT UNDER THE
RULE ONLY ASK FOR YOU KNOW WHAT
MORE LIKE WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE
HE NEVER SHOWED. IT WILL HAVE
TO COME UP WITH A NEW. YES WE
TAKE NEXT YEAR YES WE HAD THE
DEFINITELY DO THAT BUT YOU TOOK
THE CAKE THIS YEAR. CENTER
WINNER SO CONGRATULATIONS. AT
ANY HERTZBERG BEANIE. I JUST I
I'M SORRY I WILL NOT AGREE TO
THE GOOD LORD IS NOT HAVE AN
APPEAL PROCESS. BASE IN GERMANY
THIS IS GOING TO BE OUR FINAL
LEGISLATIVE HEARING OF THE EAR
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT ALSO TO
BE ON THE SAFE THANK YOU TO THE
GOV IN FIGHT TEAM AND WE GIVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE PLEASE. SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GREAT JOB
WHAT IS IT THANK YOU OVERLY FOR
OFFICE WHO'S BEEN ON IT THE
ENTIRE YEAR ONCE A DAY. GIVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE WELL. THANK
YOU ARE SORRY TO BEEN AMAZING.
CARS ARGENTINE ME AND OF COURSE
WE'LL SEE. YOU ON OCTOBER
TWENTY FIFTH. WHAT TIME ONE PM
ONE PM AT THE M. T. C.
HEADQUARTERS. IN SENATOR
WINNERS CITY. SO AND IT IS AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON SCOOTERS.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE AG GOOD
STUFF IT'S GOING TO BE AWESOME
ALL RIGHT WE'RE ALL GONNA GET
THERE BY SCOOTER TO. THAT'S
GREAT. I THINK FROM HEALDSBURG
IT'S PRETTY EASY TO GET THE
RESCUE YEAH IT'S CAN BE SIMPLE
IT'LL BE GREAT. WE WILL ALL BE
ARRESTED SO. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED